David Moyes was informed in person by
the club's chief executive ed Woodward
this morning at the Carrington training
ground that his term as United manager
will be ending after not even one full
season in charge because he was hired
with what seemed to be a huge show of
faith the six year contract and the
backing of Sir Alex Ferguson that he was
the man who could follow the greatest
manager that English football's probably
ever known at this club those hopes the
hopes that in in Moyes we there was a
second Ferguson to continue his work
were dashed and proved wrong simply by a
succession of poor results the Glazer
family have given him time ins had to
transfer windows the summer and then
January a great deal of money to try and
turn around a squad that was aging but
he took over the champions of England
that last made 11 points clear of the
field after nine months in charge United
and not even the best of the best there
outside the Champions League places
there behind Tottenham in the league
there and perhaps most damning there
behind Everton the club that more is
left to join United so he doesn't really
have a case on the field to be retained
he's also I think behind the scenes
United has become a really quite
difficult place to work and has been a
pretty poisonous atmosphere the
difficult atmosphere among senior
players at the training ground and even
within the boardroom it has not been a
happy ship so this is perhaps an
everyone's sad for David Moyes but for
the Glazer family they've invested so
much of borrowed money in this club and
need the club to continue succeeding to
pay the interest on those loans and to
keep their investment afloat I think
this is an inevitable decision